Epstein documentary dude first of all I
said this [ __ ] about pizza gate a long
time ago about how I didn't think there
was it was a thing and I didn't think
about [ __ ] now there were there were
no pedophile rings in Hollywood and then
people were like what about Jeffrey
Epstein man it's pretty good case closed
about the Jeffrey hip Britain and I'm
like yeah do it Jeffrey Epstein wasn't
in Hollywood man Jeffrey Epstein was a
billionaire because he like [ __ ] move
people's money's around and bought
businesses and [ __ ] and of course some
people in Hollywood are bad just because
[ __ ] some people are bad you know how
it's like I [ __ ] did the thing about
pizza gay people like well that's
because obviously Chris I saw the guy
hide he's a pedo well he's obviously
[ __ ] at something look at him look at
him look at him [ __ ] look laughs look
at him look like what he said it that
something doesn't mean it does when
they're a [ __ ] lawyer and but I saw
the Jeffrey Epstein thing and man that
dude looks a little bit [ __ ] I mean
that dude is a sociopath but the [ __ ]
documentary on Netflix it was called
like the Epstein [ __ ] files or
whatever the [ __ ] it's called Epstein
pure money or some [ __ ] it was called
help Epstein healthy on the go is what
it was Epstein [ __ ] facial scrub
grand on the go [ __ ] green good for
the earth go leap directed by Lea
Michele directed by Lea Michelle Gellar
and and and dude and he [ __ ] molested
so many women and girls and it's so
[ __ ] up and dude the guy just dating
at the end of the [ __ ] documentary
and this is all you can't ruin a
documentary I'm not ruining the
documentary the dot at the end of the
thing he was like he moved his money
around so the victims couldn't be paid
like this guy was such a piece of [ __ ]
and then he killed himself that's other
thing too that I disagree with a lot of
people I want people are like well he
killed himself he didn't get to live out
his sentence and that sucks he escaped
the pain dude [ __ ] that
you know how probably can't painful
killing yourself is probably hurts a lot
dude but also he didn't kill himself
dude the cameras didn't work and the
cops were sleeping the guards and
Epstein hung himself by the way he
didn't even [ __ ] I don't even think
he jumped off something
I think he just like tried to sit down
really quickly and [ __ ] hang himself
and broke his neck doing it and the
coroner or whatever the [ __ ] they call
him the forensics medical guy was like
um no this has never happened this is
extremely rare and that means it didn't
[ __ ] happen dude Epstein got choked
dude so guy walks into the [ __ ] thing
paid a guard what a million three
million four million dollars these
[ __ ] are billionaires that were
[ __ ] jerking off on a massage table
with high school girls you you wouldn't
[ __ ] cover it up for 10 million
dollars if you've got ninety five
billion dollars of course you would so
they paid them a giggle eight guard just
so you know I'm gonna let the [ __ ]
I'm gonna change your life you're gonna
be driving around or whatever the [ __ ]
for and shits you want your houses are
gonna have the many doors you're gonna
have a pool and you might even have to
just let me get into that [ __ ]
and choke them please and they go like
this okay don't tell anybody and the guy
says why would I tell anybody if I tell
anybody then I got to go to jail too and
then they both [ __ ] jumped like the
Toyota commercials that they go
Eila they jump and they stop and and
they were freeze-frame with their
[ __ ] legs up I love what you do for
me joy that's what happens and then
[ __ ] he goes I'll be right back and
then goes kink on opens the thing and
goes tiptoes near [ __ ] Jeffrey
Epstein and goes like this remember me
and then [ __ ] chokes him so hard that
he broke his neck man it's obviously
what happened and I'm no conspiracy
theorist dude I don't believe in any
conspiracies [ __ ] I'll Kazim's
razor or whatever the [ __ ] they say it's
probably what the [ __ ] you think it is
but this [ __ ] this Jeffrey Epstein
[ __ ] somebody murdered this guy
and dude I'm a detective man I walk into
the [ __ ] epstein thing and I go like
this well he [ __ ] he sat down into a
[ __ ] noose hmm something seems fishy
Wow hmm and you guys already think you
know what happens you think he [ __ ]
killed himself
Jeffrey Epstein killed himself I don't
know a little too premature a little too
premature of a [ __ ] decision for my
liking
and then put on sunglasses and leave
dude out the window and that Epstein was
trash huh there's other [ __ ]
too and the [ __ ] documentary never
told us who it was they just showed
pictures they said one thing about the
[ __ ] prince guy and then one thing
about [ __ ] Bill Clinton and then they
showed one picture of [ __ ] Chris
Tucker and I'm like oh who did it I want
to know the other people that were in it
jerking off on massage tables with
[ __ ] high school kid I want to know
about these [ __ ] dude the whole
thing ended and it was like and I would
and we all looked at each other we were
like what the [ __ ] man we don't get to
know who else did it
expose these [ __ ] all they said
so many different times they were like
oh well we don't know well yeah there
were tons of other high profile high
profile people that that that tried to
that [ __ ] me and and when I was 14 and
then and then they were and they were
like show people on a plane and you'd be
like oh yeah there's Kevin Spacey but
did he do it but say it but did he do it
but say it oh there's a picture of Chris
Tucker but did he do it say Bill Clinton
did he do it say oh he was on the island
oh he said he wasn't but he was on the
island 26 times okay but did it do it
say it because you're saying Jeffrey
Epstein did it tell us man that's why
I'm watching the documentary I'm here
for the juicy bits I want to know dude I
want to know if Chris Tucker was like
color Dan this was a good the worst
impression of all time Towelie
why is my Chris Tucker impression tally
dude daddy
I want to do it if they had one scene
where's like and then Chris Tucker went
like this I would have been like okay
worth it the four episodes worth it you
know how many [ __ ] pictures of the
[ __ ] house they showed and the
Jeffrey Epstein documentary shit's so
many pictures of them of a tracking shot
of his [ __ ] West Palm Beach House I
don't give a [ __ ] about that show more
pictures in the plane you hinted at Bill
Clinton you hinted that [ __ ] Kevin
Spacey yeah you said it [ __ ] the
prints - did it - Andrew prints guy and
you show one picture of Chris Tucker and
you think that's of Isis Shimon more
pegs so I'm a b-boy who did head chicks
who are women now who did lemon know
dude I would be that guy man I am a
tattle-tale [ __ ] yeah dude that's why I
respect that six nine core plancha guy
cuz he was just like oh [ __ ] I'm caught
well they were like well if you tell us
and he was like stop right there it was
Dave and they were like Kay well you're
you're free cool I'll be rich now
hell yeah snitched oh hell yeah I
snitched dude man I think about that how
many Bacon's think so many times I know
I've told you guys about that but when I
was in a [ __ ] place called burgees in
LA cañada I would go and I would get the
tuna melt and I would say hey can I get
bacon on it and the guy would always say
sure how many Bacon's and I think about
that every two months
how many Bacon's and I cooked bacon
every morning because my girl won't do
it and I make how many Bacon's three or
eight three or four why did I say eight
oh cool good cool got a tumor all good
that's all good dude someone call the
doctor - tumor I said eight and settle
for sauce organ after three by the way
oh